bon
[Musique]
l'idée ce n'est pas un camp de
recrutement nous interdisons cela ce
n'est pas un camp de recrutement au les
gens viennent piquer les jeunes pour les
amener aux états unis où ou qu'ils
puissent être transférés d'adopter
l'idée c'est de permettre à tous ceux
qui ne sont pas spécialement licenciés
qui découvrent l'activité leur permettre
de pouvoir travailler de pouvoir jeudi
et s'épanouir aussi il est question
aussi de permettre à ceux qui ont une
licence qui sont un peu aguerris de
pouvoir le pouvoir de pouvoir
s'entraîner et puis il y à un troisième
niveau dans ce cas c'est ce qu'ils sont
très aguerris qui ont l'habitude qui ont
l'habitude de faire des performances
d'effectuer les performances et ben
voilà donc alors on leur offre cet
espace qui leur permet en tout cas de de
progresser et afin qu'il devienne
meilleur en tout cas pour l'année
prochaine
ça
l'idée c'est d'abord de permettre aux
gamins de travailler leurs fondamentaux
leur technique individuelle mais aussi
de participer aussi je dirais très
humblement l'information à la formation
des coaches
[Musique]